إذا كنت سأكون هناك الآن بالطبع
سيجدونني وسيفعلون
شيئًا ما ولكن الحمد لله أنا هنا
[موسيقى]
لذا
[موسيقى
] فالطول كما أخبرتك أنه لم يتم تغييره مطلقًا ،
لا يمكنني  مقارنتها بالحيوان
الحيوان أفضل بكثير منهم ،
لا يمكنني مقارنتها بأي إنسان
على هذا الكوكب ، فهم أكثر خطورة
من أي شخص تفكر فيه
[موسيقى]
يعلنون أننا نسامح
الجميع ،
أنا آسف لأنني  عفواً لغتي ،
لدي الكثير من مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بهم ، فهم
يطردون الناس ويطلبون
مترجمًا
يسألون عن الأشخاص الموجودين في
الجيش ويسألون عن كل
هؤلاء الأشخاص وسوف يقتلونهم
[موسيقى]
حدث الكثير من التقدم
بالعودة إلى أفغانستان الآن ، كان كل
شيء صفريًا ،
لكن قلقي حقًا هو
ما ستفعله النساء بالبقاء في المنزل ،
لا شيء ،
لا
مدرسة ، الجامعات